And everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and I just wanted to create this short video
to help new comers to our site understand what we do.
You're at our main cancer site now.
We also have a sister site that we help people with autoimmune diseases, Lyme disease, other
chronic diseases, toxicity issues and detox issues, and on the bottom of one of our website
pages, you can click and be directed to that if you don't have a cancer diagnosis.
But right now, we're going to mainly talk about cancer and understand that really we
are a ministry.
So that's the biggest part of what we're doing is trying to help educate people.
And I truly mean the word doctor actually means teacher.
I really believe that is one of my spiritual gifts and I want to try to be able to break
down complex things to make them easier to understand.
I think that's what a good teacher does.
So I'll understand you don't have to become a member or you don't have to schedule a case
review.
You don't have to start with us or anything like that to utilize our website to read my book
to self-educate.
We have thousands of videos that you can, that I've created over the years, that you
can go through and help teach yourself how to be able to best take care of yourself.
I created all these courses, different subjects, our flagship courses, the stop fighting cancer
courses.
It goes through my book, stop fighting cancer book in detail.
And depending on what you have going on, these other courses might be more applicable.
So we're here really trying to help you, but I'm here to help you too.
So a lot of people that start with maybe a course, start with investigating our website and
gaining information, then we'll choose to schedule a case review with me.
And a case review is where the first steps you're communicating with me.
It's a half hour call where we talk about what's going on in your life.
And what you really, your goals are, whether you're trying to overcome cancer.
And I can give you some suggestions and point you in the right direction there.
Or you refer to us and you want to start as a comprehensive patient.
Most of our cancer patients start that way.
So but we can't break down our program too.
So if you're just looking to get a right machine, a lot of people are looking at it or just
a nutritional protocol or just want to order labs or get a genetic review, those things
are possible too.
But they have to start with a case review to see if we're a good fit.
You might not like me.
That's okay.
And I might not think I can help you.
And if I can't, I'll direct you in another way.
If I can, I'm not here for everybody.
So we understand that.
But like I said, most people with cancer do start with our full private membership or comprehensive
membership.
That's where we get a cheek swab test.
And from the cheek swab test, I test on what specific nutritional dietary and supplement
and et cetera that I'm going to make recommendations for you.
So we get a very specific unique protocol for you.
If you read any of my stuff on cancer, I don't believe that there is a one size fits all
for cancer.
I think everybody is unique.
Everybody is very different.
I've said it hundreds of times, you're going to have twin sisters with breast cancer,
their protocols going to be different.
Because your body is different and it's functioning different and your protocol can change
over time.
Sometimes when we're looking for a fuel source for the cancer, the fuel source can change.
Cancer is constantly trying to stay alive.
That's where we recommend future cheek swab retesting.
We have to because your body is always changing.
So we use different rife machines.
I'll select what's going to be the best one for you, discuss that with you, obviously.
And what I think is going to be the best tool for your case.
We do genetic testing.
We do so much that you really have to look at the website.
I'm not going to repeat what's on that.
But our full membership is fairly inclusive of a lot of things that are going to help people.
So we want to be able to best help you and best answer your questions and be there for
you.
And always in everything, you never, my motto has always been, you never stop asking the right
questions.
You have to always be asking why?
Why do I have this?
What's the cause?
If you don't uncover the cause of your disease, whether it's cancer or something else, how
are you going to get better?
I just don't get it.
So many cancer patients I talk to, they've asked their oncologists, what's the cause of this?
And they get either a blank stare or, well, I don't know, well, this is just what you got.
This is what you're, there isn't reason.
And we got to try to dig to that.
That's what we can get to with the cheek swab testing, at least our best understanding of what
that is.
And then again, we don't treat cancer.
We don't treat disease, nor do we diagnose here, but we're treating people with issues.
Our body isn't working correctly, let's get it working correctly.
I really believe in this quote, the gift of knowledge is beautiful, but it is truly the
application of knowledge.
That's wisdom.
That can be life changing.
So it's not just about knowing, but it's no way to do it, how to apply that, it kind of
be in front of them to be able to apply that.
That's what our goal is.
So no matter what you do, whether you schedule a case review with me and you move forward
or we just talk, and maybe it's not the right fit, know that regardless, we're going to
be praying for you and know that God has a plan.
Even in all of this, even in our struggles and dumb, we're just going to give him glory.
Thank you.
And we hope that we'll talk soon.
All right.
Bye-bye.